what happened with Dilbert all right so
this is a comic if you've never seen a
Dober com you probably have they're
super popular [__] comics and he just
goes on I think he's on like a podcast I
don't know he's doing some type of
Internet interview
it's his own thing he has a YouTube
channel like a hundred thousand
subscribers 118 000 or something I think
he just hit live bro yeah he's just
talking about himself he's like two
minutes we can skip around but it gets
pretty good
so if if you know nearly half of All
Blacks
are not okay with white people according
to this poll not according to me uh
that's a hate group and I don't want to
have anything to do with them the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
do you know you started this off by
saying he identifies as a black person
no way y'all miss that
he literally said I identify as a black
president of identity I've identified as
a black person for a while now but he
was like now because of his poll it's a
poll that came out that said like uh
black people I don't know I don't know
what the exact poll black people don't
like white people or something and so he
was like now since half of these people
don't like me they're a hate group and I
don't want to be a part of it if he's
black and he said he don't want to be a
part of that hate group he feels like
black people are the hate group because
the poll says like 50 or 60 of all black
people don't like white people oh he as
a black person he doesn't want to be
part of that exactly so even though he's
black he just wants to get away from
black that's what he said he said no he
said he's he actually said I'm
re-identifying back is white
and I don't want to be a part of this
hate group is that really part of this
I heard it this morning I didn't hear
that Scott Adams
so is this maybe just like a bit that's
a bad bit bro why I'll do a bit that's
gonna cost you everything because if
he's saying oh I'm black and now it's
like I can say whatever I want now well
yeah he if you identify as black you can
be critical of black people yeah that's
kind of what he's doing he's asking for
the permission slip well he said he used
to identify as black no longer then
re-identified his wife and then went on
that ring now why is he saying he's
doing that he goes I identify but as a
black man then I found out that my
people are hateful I can't identify as
that yeah and then he tries to quote Don
Lemon he's like I was getting this from
Don Lemon yes I just want to know why
like what makes you wake up in the
morning and say I'm gonna set fire to
everything I've I've built
yeah
that's corny bro with Scott Adams this
is corny like why there's a thing that
happens with these cartoon creators and
Patrice talked about this with Seth
MacFarlane is like you get jealous of
your creation and you start wanting
credit and this is maybe his like
finally Dilbert gets all these all this
credit everybody reads it nobody knows
who this man is 25 years it's a great
life what is it I agree what is Dilbert
Pro he's a goddamn white character with
no mouth he's a oh he's like um
he's like an office employee what it's
like an office space type [__] yeah this
is like the first office there's like a
like a comic strip in like 80s 90s that
was like you look like a Simpson with
Down Syndrome bro
that's Bart's brother they keep tucked
away he looks like
they don't want nobody to know about me
I wish he was if you told your brothers
I really wish he just did it as a comic
strip like if he just did like hey we
got to get away from black people but
just as like a cartoon I feel like it'd
be a lot more palatable you know but
this is what he does this is what he's
known for yeah that's a great point
right by the way there's no better way
to get your message across than art that
could have been a funny series of strips
so we're trying to be an ally yeah and
realizing like man I can't win with any
anybody yeah that would have been funny
as [__] yeah Gilbert should identify as
black yeah Dilbert's in a dashiki he's
like yes I'm trans racer now because now
you're making fun of all of this [__]
right like how you can just identify
what you want to identify yes he got out
of his Lane that's the issue that could
be her
that would be [__] hilarious but I
think in the past you said you um prefer
people being overtly racist so you know
like who to stay away from no I prefer
but why would I do it as a I prefer but
why would I do that if if I'm him I mean
what reason do you what benefits what
happens when you get all the money you
need like he doesn't need more money so
he's okay to lose interest
he's either losing his mind or he
doesn't need more money and yeah the
only thing he needs is to not be around
as many black people and he's just
sharing that he could can't you do that
with money though that's my point
segregate it's all about class
segregation in the new segregation he
already said he's in a new neighborhood
with no balloon yeah so if you've
achieved it why do you need a share I'm
assuming it's the JK Rowling thing it's
like you see something that's happening
in society like he's mentioned another
clip I could pull it up but basically he
was like every day I go on social media
and I see black people beating up white
people and I'm over it I'm sick of it
he's seeing something that he thinks is
an injustice no one's talking about he's
like you know what I'm going to speak
about it what did JK do she just spoke
up about the trans stuff she felt like
uh her Womanhood was being threatened
yeah and she's like all about she tweets
she's like you know women are women and
trans women are not women blah blah and
she just ahead of her time because a lot
of people are feeling that way now a lot
of people are pushing back on yeah
people look at her and they're like you
have a billion dollars you live an
amazing life why would you sacrifice
your whole reputation your whole Legacy
all this [__] you made for just an
opinion that you have that you don't
you're not even going to be here to see
before with you that's my point with
these people like this like why like I
prefer that if you feel that way let me
know you feel that way I don't want him
to feel that way he's not disagreeing
with you he's just saying from Dilbert's
point of view exactly why would you
speak this up like what do you have to
do like you just don't want to make more
money you got enough money
he don't he don't that's what happens
when you if you're having all the money
you're willing to just say whatever the
[__] why make [__] money if you're
not gonna say if you burnt your legacy
down he don't care I don't care Jesus
his legacy is a cartoon with no mouth I
think he also he has no legs
I think he looks at this and he's like
there's an injustice happening in
America black people are being of white
people and no one's saying anything I'm
gonna be the one to stand on it and in
50 years people go yeah that guy was
right I don't know there's a lot of
there's a lot a lot a lot of
marginalized communities in this country
right if you're a marginalized if you're
a black guy yeah like hold on a second
you may not be part of a hate group yeah
but there's a lot of things to hate yeah
I mean there's a lot of racial Injustice
that you can hate in this country
there's a lot of systemic racism that we
all should hate if you call yourself an
American I just want to go back to some
of the Mark said I think what happens is
when people get incredibly famous for
doing inconsequential [__] they try to
project that Fame onto something that
they deem more important so if you're
known as like a cartoonist that makes
silly jokes about the office yeah what
can I do that has significance what can
I do that makes change what can I do
that is you know gonna gonna write the
world yeah you know what I mean so uh
and they get politically active in
either direction exactly so I think
that's kind of what he's doing he's like
making up for the fact that like what
he's known for is kind of frivolous but
it's okay to be known for something
privileged yeah it's beautiful it's not
even political it's just racist exactly
this is like this is white nationalist
Neo-Nazi talking points that's my point
is I think if you separate people that
do get away from black people I think
people that do racist [__] are not think
oh my I'm ruining my legacy I think
they're do they're doing it because
they're preserving their lace here
they're making a new Legacy that they
think is good they want to make a new
one
I don't think you need to just collect
like that's an important I don't think
we need to disclaim that this is racist
but my point is that recent people do
things because of their legs say not to
destroy it you know it's funny he
doesn't think it's racist
exactly he thinks he's doing something
good for us this is like to him he's
like
who did he pull no this is it this is
like this is his like ice bath
you know the people that get in the ice
bath they're like it's changed my life
like it's so he's like just you move
away from black people so it's [__]
[__] poll changed your life you're
not a stripper bro
he's been going that way yeah and now
he's and then maybe even it's when you
get enough money you don't stop caring
what people think now you start thinking
okay I got the money now Legacy yeah I
think that makes sense if you're known
for something frivolous people want to
do something more because I think they
go oh once I get money they don't be
happy then they get money and they're
still not happy and they're like oh once
they get Legacy then I'll be happy once
people respect me people don't respect
me this is this is this guy the Dilbert
guy going I'm really smart and I'm
thoughtful and I understand the world
and I'm sophisticated and people think
I'm just a little silly cartoonist
comedian I need to prove that I'm a
sophisticated thinker and it's just it's
never enough it's just the bottomless
pit yeah I'm sick of white grievance you
know what I mean especially when white
grievance is towards what is everybody
it's the same [__] with [__] uh Kyrie
Kyrie is the same exact as thing as this
guy it's like it's not good enough that
he's just great at basketball Genius of
basketball is like I need to be a
philosopher I need to be a thinker I
dream Makari is still black so being
that he's black like there's actual room
for real grief there you know what I
mean like like if you're a white male
like that like your grievances just the
fact that black people are complaining
about this country everybody got their
own grief I wouldn't take away grief
from people it's like also if you don't
know what somebody's family is going
through you don't know what somebody is
doing something it feels like grievance
though like the stuff that he's doing
and this is just like white grieving
yeah none of this makes sense yeah what
I'm just saying is just because you're a
white dude doesn't mean that you haven't
been [__] molested it doesn't mean
that you haven't seen your dad get shot
you're like there's a lot of things that
but the only thing we can relate on
those are things we can all relate to
right like if if America's issues were
just based on [__] like that yeah it'd
be different but when America's issues
are based on what we are that we have no
control of like me being black or you
know Alex being gay or like you know I
mean you know I'm so bad
you want me so no I'm just saying it
I'm just saying there's things that we
can't control and like that hinders
certain people in America and deep those
people just don't want that to be
anymore but then I will say there's room
I think for white grievance like in
[__] trains in Ohio I'm assuming
that's a white town that is just I don't
think that's white grievance yeah
I know I understand what you're saying
it's like there's like a historical
implication for the treatment that black
people events exist why does that have
anything to do with the world being flat
I don't know
I'm smarter than that and here's the
proof yeah and I'm smarter than everyone
because I'm on the [__] that no one
nobody understands and that's what and
listen it is what you spoke to earlier
what Patrice was talking about it's like
you become jealous of your creation and
you don't think that your creation uh
does Justice to your intellect yes you
need to prove how smart you are it's
like I think Kanye is a better example
than Kyrie Kanye's perfect example yeah
because Kyrie didn't even tell us what
the issue was you know what I'm saying
like he just posted that book with no
context and I guess he told us later
he's you know Finding himself and yada
yada but Kanye was on some like no I
want to be like this group of people
yeah this group of people get to
basically do whatever they want this is
just his words they get to do whatever
they want yeah they get to move however
they want and I'm jealous of that I want
that yeah so and I'm gonna [__] on them
yeah you know what I mean to show my my
love for them which is also quite
strange no he had the greatest comeback
of anybody when he he goes he goes I
love Nazis [__] you love Nazis and
there's only one way to come back from
that yeah it's I love everybody yeah
that's the only way is the only way that
you can justify saying the craziest
thing ever that's why I love everybody
is some [__] well yeah you don't
love everybody no it's not possible even
in the Bible
it got cool yeah but he might love
everybody
where was this love when you were
[__] on Pete all the goddamn time
because you had to think of Pete's 10
and a half inch penis thanks nobody
wants to think about that [__] how can
you love the man with a 10 and a half
inch penis I'm thinking about it right
now
man
do you know something you got inside him
from nah I never got inside info my guy
Pete though but still he Just Started
Loving everybody with the Nazis
that don't work that don't work but then
again it's like the all lives matter
[__] it's like oh oh yeah everybody's
lives matter same [__] that doesn't work
everybody life matter until that person
does something to your child exactly
everybody life matters all life matter
until that person does something I'm all
agreed that all lives don't matter I
think as
yeah I mean we know this you know it's
just a silly thing to even retort but
instead of accepting the fact these
people are saying black lives matter
because this country has historically
shown them that black lives matter less
than a lot of other people instead of
just acknowledging that fact yeah y'all
lives matter you don't believe that yeah
most lives matter
some
yeah
Thanos should have been more selective
though I don't want you just randomly uh
you know what I mean when he said at the
end of an end game when he was like the
only mistake I made was everybody
remembers who left when I do it this
time I'm gonna make sure y'all forget
and never knew they were here one of the
greatest lines in movie history he says
he says um as long as there are people
who knew what was they'll never they'll
never Embrace what can be
then I was like this guy got a great
idea here yeah so you want to do random
nah gotta be selected what's your
selection process a lot more it'd be
more like Frailty you ever seen Frailty
no no one of my favorite movies y'all
should all watch Frailty Frailty is
about two brothers who father
is a serial killer
but
see I'll be giving the movie away but
first it's such an old classic he's a
he's a serial killer but the reason he's
a serial killer is because he can touch
you and see the foul [__] that you've
done oh that's fire you know what I'm
saying so the people he's killing are
actually child molesters you know people
who killed their moms and got away with
it like that yes
and so the other son can also see
you know he has the same vision so you
the whole movie you're thinking these
two [__] are just crazy and
this one son is the good son because
he's not going along with it and then he
just can't see the [__] he just can't
see the [__] that's right so I would
have to have something like that where I
can actually see what you know people
have done but then again that's like
defeating the whole purpose of God
because that's the other part of Frailty
that's when I think about it as I get
older Frailty was about religion these
people believed in God but then you
taken away the whole aspect of
forgiveness like that right well that
that God might not forgive and maybe God
gave them the ability to see these
things
that's true too I mean you know we have
all these conversations about
forgiveness but how do we know if God
really forgives